three months after her home and business
in the village of fish lake flooded Pam
Webb is still waiting for financial help
from the government to put things right
this was an oak flooring that obviously
had to be taken up can't put down what
was down before flood hit households can
apply for up to five hundred pounds for
businesses it's up to two and a half
thousand and up to five thousand pounds
more can be applied for to put flood
resilience measures in place my
insurance was due for renewal on the
30th of November bearing in mind the
flood hit on the 8th of November so the
initial cover was the proposal was
pulled so I found myself not being able
to get himself insured richard partially
is found along the banks of the river
dawn for 40 years he's never seen it as
high as it was in November and thinks
that better River management including
dredging could have prevented it the
water can't get down the river for the
trees and the silt and years ago the
dawn always used to be dredged and it's
never been touched for 35 or 40 years do
you think that could have prevented the
floods in November it would have made a
big difference the Environment Agency
says dredging can be a solution but not
everywhere we do dredge in some
locations across England where it can
make a difference probably about 10
million pounds a year of dredging we do
to reduce flood risk however dredging
the haul of the river at dawn or the
holder of seven is just not technically
feasible or economically viable it will
be months before flooded areas like this
return to normality
until then residents are forced to live
in rented accommodation or static
caravans this is another bone of
contention for the residents here
staying fourth bridge it is beautiful it
was built in 1768 and it's grade 2
listed but it's narrow arches means that
it simply doesn't let the river Dom flow
through it quickly enough causing it to
back up and cause serious problems
this bridge say the people of Fish Lake
simply has to be replaced
it's also the bridge where Boris Johnson
was taken to task by angry residents the
PM has been criticized for his low
visibility approach to the more recent
flooding brought by storms Kyra and
Dennis one minister says that's to avoid
a jamboree of media here in Fish Lake
the prime minister may not be present
but the sandbags are as once again
communities are bracing themselves for
more and more rain Fraser Maud Sky News
Fish Lake